entouré d'une quinzaine d'élus du front
national sophie montel a décidé de
frapper fort son groupe ne siégera pas à
nevers pour la première assemblée
plénière délocalisé du conseil régional
pour elle cette initiative n'a pas de
sens politique
les patriotes front national ne suivra
pas la duchesse de bourgogne et ça court
dans ses pérégrinations nous estimons
qu'il y ait un siège il est à dijon
les chiffres que nous avons pour les
frais de déplacement ils sont en hausse
de plus de 30% par rapport à l'année
dernière à l'arrêt à fin septembre c'est
à dire que le dernier trimestre n'est
encore pas comptabilisé nous allons
arriver à une augmentation de ses
dépenses de 50 % en frais de déplacement
il faut stopper il faut arrêter de voilà
un déplacement à nevers je pense que
nous allons arriver à des coûts de plus
100 mille euros entre les frais de
déplacement du personnel d'hébergement
de restauration pour le personnel du
conseil régional et les élus pour
l'heure la présidence de la région n'a
pas chiffré ses frais délocalisée de
session plénière du conseil régional par
an c'était un souhait de la présidente
du fai est votée en juin dernier par
l'assemblée pour la majorité ne s'agit
pas là d'un gadget mais d'un signal fort
envoyé aux territoires plus que le
symbole la présence de l'assemblée à
nevers il y aura d'autres villes qui
sont ils peuvent sortir un point de
sentiment d'appartenance à la grande
région
eh bien nous reconnaîtrons cette
appartenance par une présence forte qui
est doublé par deux jours de présence de
la présidence dans la nièvre où elle va
rencontrer l'ensemble des forces vives
des élus des associations des
entreprises
l'absence du groupe fn ne devrait pas
poser de problème de quorum pour la
tenue de l'assemblée à nevers pour la
prochaine réunion plénière délocaliser
le parti frontiste devrait être cette
fois-ci présent mais entend déposer
plusieurs amendements sur les rapports
présentés par la majorité